mr. Jerry Seinfeld he's got a new
Netflix comedy special dropping today
but the real celebration started six
days ago when Jerry turned 66 so what
did you do is was it like a typical
birthday did you just like hang out or
did you do something different
my birthday is really all about Italian
food my wife is a great cook and we had
calzone we had Dede we had red wine and
she made chocolate cake you magnificent
there's your wife do your kids do they
actually think you're as funny as we
think you are when I'm trying to be
funny and I'm not
they love to just stare at me and just
go really I'm one of your new [ __ ] so
that's the worst thing that they'll say
is this something you're working on dad
Jerry's three kids might be his toughest
critics but we know his wife of 20 years
jessica is the one who really calls the
shots even when it comes to his new show
Jerry Seinfeld 23 hours to kill your
life sucks my life sucks too
perhaps not quite as much I noticed you
jumped out of it of a helicopter to
start this mess a lot and in the credits
I did see where she gave you permission
I very rarely get scared by anything
mm-hmm
but that was scary that was a little
scary it's four stories is like jumping
off a four-story building Indian you
look like a major badass meanwhile
Gerry's iconic sitcom is set to debut on
Netflix next year so does that mean
we'll get a Seinfeld reunion soon like
the way you think maybe we can get like
you know a reunification of the cast for
a good cause
no don't think about it I haven't talked
about it
Kramer the last time you hit your head
what's Mary Hart on TV yeah
George what are you doing my god
which would would save the world we
would do it but I don't think it would
no more
[Music]